and any ecosystem you'll find a delicate
balance between predator and prey some
well-known predators include Panthera
Leo Ursus arctos and star of the 1987
film predator predator now examples of
prey include a Rick tool Auguste Knik
ulis Gallus Gallus domesticus and
weighing in at 58 pounds soaking wet
diminutive homo Novis curiously a close
relative of Gallus Gallus domesticus
[Music]
Cooper you will stop would you mind
dropping me up closer to my house you
know I'm not allowed to do that what if
I did your taxes sorry kiddo I could
have gotten you a nice refund the
perilous journey from the bus stop to my
front door was 90 7.5 meters
fYI insisting on using the metric system
in East Texas is another reason I was
hunted by predators
homo Novis needs a yoohoo jiu-jitsu I'm
decided to learn self-defense why I'm
quite small and will be for several
years maybe even more if I'm a late
bloomer
that's big maybe they take after him we
both like my mom I think that's where
the similarities end you know one of the
books mentioned a Vietnamese martial art
vovinam I'm in Bluebell Wow
don't be impressed so you get when your
mom buys a uniform do you remember any
of it I don't even know when the boat is
the book says jujitsu is based on using
your attackers momentum against them
it's just physics come at me like we're
not you
well I'm new to this so maybe just walk
quickly and why buzz when I get to you
I'll use your inertia to take you down
okay
[Music]
and when does inertia take me down
[Music]
[Music]
called an outside eye she gouramis what
happens next
that depends is this your foot or mine
[Music]